assalamualaikum to all the viewers that
have made it peace and blessings to
anyone that hasn't do you want to give a
little bit of a summary of what we
talked about so far not about the things
that I was kind of teaching you and
going over but more of like how Andrew
take kind of inspired you a little bit
yeah yeah so I've been watching Andrew
Tate for about six or seven months and I
I tend to agree with a lot of the things
that he says and I also reflect
on what he said and think about it a lot
in my day-to-day life and how it how it
applies to me
um and after critically thinking about
stuff and going through it and seeing
him converting to Islam
um I feel as though
it's the True Religion and I'm here to
convert but also to answer even more
questions that I've really thought about
in the past six months and I found the
three Muslims Channel
um I guess through Andrew Tate because I
was just searching around because I was
curious about Islam and um your channel
has really enlightened me as well
beautiful bro listen all good is from
God from Allah so glad that you you know
we could play a piece in the puzzle in
facilitating this this relay of
knowledge bro
um on knowledge understanding we were
talking about how we shouldn't just keep
it we should share it with the world
um so Ben actually just you know got on
a call with me
um like many subscribers and he just
asked me some questions about Islam I
was answering it and then part way
through I was like you know there's more
benefit if you know more people can be
in on this conversation matter of fact
the reason we started this podcast was
because me Rami and Angelo The Three
Brothers we were already doing these
conversations anyway so we realized why
don't we just hit record now and just
share with the world that's what we did
about like a year and a half ago when we
started this channel
um some people always ask because
they're like you know doesn't it take a
lot of time to like talk and schedule
these calls and I was like thinking back
I'm like no bro we were doing these
anyway we were having these calls anyway
might as well just hit record now and
let people feel like they're in on these
real conversations
um so I gave a little bit about the
basics of Islam to you right you already
have pretty clear understanding you're
coming into it rationally right not
emotionally or anything like that we
talked about belief in one God why you
know polytheism or belief in multiple
gods would make no sense we talked about
the five pillars of Islam do you
remember any of them bro quick q a if
you get it any wrong no problem yeah
so the first pillar is believing in one
God right yes so it's the is the shahada
which is just belief that there's
nothing worthy of worship except God
Alone Allah alone and the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him is the last
and final messenger so that's kind of
what the shahada is in English
um what were the other four
uh the second one is prayer so praying
five times a day
throughout the day
um and you you said that it was like
five to ten minutes praying a day yeah
yeah so if you you want to really take
your time bro 10 minutes 20 minutes even
if you really want to but ideally it's
just a little bit like the Sunnah or or
following the teaching of the Prophet
it's just it's just a little break from
your day it's just a little pattern
Interruption when we're consumed in the
Dunya in our worldly material Affairs
you just take a little bit of a break
and worship the Creator
um yeah so what about number three
uh is number three Ramadan no so number
three was zakat the paying the tax yeah
the tax to 2.5 yes correct so just of
your excessive wealth savings that
you're not using just to give towards
charity those that are more in need
matter of fact I just got off a
recording a few hours ago with Angel and
we were talking about there's a Hadith
where I believe it was uh Omar who was a
companion of the Prophet
um peace be upon him so he he found a
guy who basically had a little bit of a
pouch like a little bit of a belly and
he he pointed at that and he's like what
is that and the guy was like oh this is
a blessing from God you know and he's
like no if only you knew that that would
have been better elsewhere
you know just to show that you know how
many of us are just feasting going in on
these blessings so-called but we're just
neglecting our neighbors neglecting our
brothers you know that have less so
that's kind of what number three is the
zakat
um number four do you remember what that
was Ramada yes correct the Ramadan and
then what about number five uh and
number five was
I don't recall number five okay no
worries number five was the pilgrimage
which is called Hajj oh yeah yeah going
to Mecca once in your life if you're
able to and just to quickly uh let the
viewers in on something I did talk to
Ben about why and how we do Ramadan so
Ramadan it's not just you know food
abstaining from food you're abstaining
from water as well
um intimacy anything with your spouse
you know just you know all these things
medications you're just taking a break
during the day
um and then obviously all those things
are permissible after their Maghrib
which is the fourth prayer so from
Sunset all the way until the next budget
you can you know enjoy all the things
that you're abstaining from during the
day
and Allah says in the Quran that we have
prescribed fasting to you
um or Ramadan fasting to you in hopes
that you achieve taqwa which is God
Consciousness because the whole point of
the whole day is you're just saying no
but you saying no to something is you
saying yes to something else which is
the creator yeah so all day you're
basically saying no I don't want food oh
I'm so hungry oh I could eat food you
know what maybe no one would even find
out you know maybe my parents are
upstairs or my family's downstairs I
could go in on these these cookies or
whatever No One's Gonna Know
but here's the thing God's watching
right so you're constantly literally
ingraining your mind the god
Consciousness during Ramadan and we also
know we'll do the water you found a
little bit of a surprise
um because most people when they do
intermittent fasting or long fasting is
just obtaining from food we talked about
some of the benefits too of the dry
fasting like autophagy and cellular
cleansing
um and then with Hajj again pretty
similar pretty self-explanatory notice
how also with the five pillars of Islam
too they go from high frequency to low
frequency so the shahada is very
frequent 24 7 it's like a belief like I
talked about right you look at the
second thing now it's going to be which
one
prayers Lord daily now so it's just five
times a day that's the minimum you can
obviously do more voluntary ones um so
now it's daily right the third one and
the fourth one are yearly so annually
the fifth one is just once in a lifetime
um cool so you did mention you have some
more questions uh yeah please let me
know so before I get into that I just
wanted to
um say I the questions that I ask here
are probably mentioned somewhere in the
Quran
um but but I think that it's really good
to have some clarification especially in
today's world where there's a lot of
complication right
um and then also another thing I wanted
to say is that Islam is
God is inviting you to to come to Islam
and you're not forced to join and
everyone has the choice in life to
follow God or follow their desires and
no one no one from Islam is forcing you
and I I think that as I get more
immersed
um I I realize that
um it's everyone's Choice whether they
want to be part of God yes
and follow his path
um so yeah so I'll just get right into
it so I I have a few questions about uh
wives
um I I feel like that's probably a
pretty common common thing very very
common please go in and by the way just
give a quick disclaimer bro y'all are
probably wondering why is fire the
biggest Layman out of all three of them
answering these questions because
unfortunately on house busy itomi's busy
too
um the romy's a little bit sick guys
keep him in your dwells he's just
battling an illness right now uh but
unfortunately you know you all have to
have me but it's all good inshallah so
let's go in
uh yeah so so how should I combat my
desire for a woman
um
you know like the desire of having sex
before marriage and stuff like that yeah
I go about that okay beautiful question
bro we get this question asked a lot and
they're usually from reverts and new
Muslims slash non-muslims even that are
kind of on the edge about you know
accepting Islam so this thing about
casual sex and promiscuity sex before
marriage I want to kind of categorize
that into one category and then I want
to categorize
um the second category which is still
sex before marriage it's still
fornication but it's not when you're
married to the woman yet but you do see
yourself wanting to marry her what I
mean by this is category a is just
basically spreading your seed with
random women strange women you just meet
them whatever you have no intention you
know the typical promiscuous casual sex
life the second one's kind of like you
know what I do want to marry this girl
eventually but maybe I'm not ready for
marriage maybe she's not ready for
marriage maybe financially you know all
of this rational logical
um excuses and therefore before you're
still partaking in sex because shaytan
the devil is telling you in your mind
you're already going to marry her anyway
eventually so you're either going to do
it now or later why wait right beautiful
so which one of these would you want me
to tackle first
um
what interests me the most is having sex
before marriage when you have the idea
that you want to get married
right so it's like the girl where it's
like you definitely do want to get
married too yeah cool okay beautiful so
in Islam we have the Nikka what is the
Nikka it is a religious and also
legislative so it's also an islamically
legal contract between a man and a woman
when they're about to get married what
this is is it's very similar but very
different from the Western traditional
marriage right so when you look at
Western marriage it's going to be you
know
um people coming Gathering they do the
vows what does that really even mean
there's nothing really contractual when
you look at a Nika which is the the
Islamic marriage agreement there are
very specific terms and agreements
there's rights there's roles there's
responsibilities so when you look at a
man
it's his obligation to be able to
provide for the woman's living expenses
basic things food shelter that type of
stuff
um spending money on her uh protecting
her right if any anything was to happen
he has to put his life on the line for
her and the family these are like
responsibilities of the man and
similarly women have responsibilities as
well right but they also have rights
um for one another as well such as you
know intimacy
um companionship understanding that type
of stuff so this is what is done through
a Nika now conventionally today we'll
see a lot of what's called Haram
relationships so Haram meaning you know
impermissible relationship meaning it's
still not casual promiscuous whatever
not like a hookup it's like they still
have the intention of one day marrying
now this is something that's also called
Haram relationship why is it wrong
because you haven't done that Nikka yet
so I want you to understand one thing
once you do that you need two witnesses
right
minimum of two male Witnesses you need
what is called the Mahar which is kind
of like a dowry right so the man gives a
little bit of like a gift it could be
money it doesn't have to be Financial as
well
um and you need the permission of the
Wali which is the which is a woman's
father right so it's very similar to
like the biblical type of marriage as
well
um but very different in some ways
because this is very clear once this is
done this is this can this ceremony can
be very quick doesn't have to be long
um you don't need a lot of people this
itself is just the marriage itself I
want you to send marriage is different
than wedding right so the wedding the
actual event it's called the walima this
is optional it's not obligatory it's not
required it's just something that comes
after okay now with this Nikka you're
also it's it's also kind of an oath that
you're taking in front of Allah in front
of God the Creator so there I want you
to understand also the severity now of a
lot of things too into into how much
responsibility you have now versus just
you know being with any woman on the
street this is like now there's a
religious obligation now
so if push comes to shove if she gets
pregnant if there's more commitment
there you feel more obliged to take on
those commitments because Allah God it's
it's you know a lot of non-muslim
YouTubers that are in self-improvement
on YouTube they even they understand us
about Islam they call it the god-level
accountability that you don't get
outside of religion specifically I think
you know some of the people I'm talking
about now when it comes to this this
realm and domain this is why we do the
Nikka additionally when you look at a
lot of you know verses in the Quran like
in Surah al-imran or Surah which is the
third and fourth
um chapters of the Quran it's very clear
that Islam and marriage was there one of
the main things right
um that we have specific legislative
laws in marriage is to preserve lineage
so lineage is something extremely
important when you look at today you
know a lot of rappers rapping over this
about this not having fathers not
knowing you know who the father is and
and you know how how devastating it is
to the psychology of a kid
um and not just that when you look at
inheritance to how much Injustice Could
Happen how much you know fake parenting
and stuff like that I literally saw a
post on Reddit the other day with a girl
saying that you know one of uh you know
my my husband is not the father of my
kids should I tell them should I not
what should I do you know yeah so so
these things are there to be preserved
in Islam right so that's why the Nika
the marriage is absolutely important
that you have because once it's done
it's like there's no doubt anymore that
these two got married right it's a it's
recording that there's a record of that
so later if let's say someone comes
let's say she gets pregnant right and
it's he's actually not the father it's
someone else they have that in writing
it's like a valid ground to a divorce
now because they know that actually got
married compare that with like a normal
casual relationship it's like oh you
cheated but okay what does that even
really mean did you cheat because you
were just not really taking any
accountability being with her anyway so
someone else just did it while you were
with her it's it's not as severe as if
there's you know there's there's no
legal grounds anymore do you know what I
mean so that's one thing another thing
too is when the kids are born they know
who the father is they know who the
mother is everything's official and I
want you to understand too the Nika
itself is not anything serious like a
western wedding you know you you put six
months of money on a ring big proposal
go down on one knee Instagram moment
everyone knows it's nothing like that
and the cat can be just between you the
woman the father
um the Sheikh who's gonna do the Nikka
um two witnesses can be done in five
minutes very simple very inexpensive too
the prophet peace be upon Him mentioned
that those that are the best weddings or
marriages that Allah in are those that
are the cheapest ones too because you
know what the intention of the other the
party is yeah
yeah
um
so so with that like how
is it possible to get islamically
married like you were talking about and
uh and not get buried in like a court of
law in your country is that allowed okay
so very very good question uh we get
this asked a lot too
is it possible to get islamically
married doesn't get a Nikka but not yet
legally married
I will answer that with somethinguendo
it is the same as it is possible to
drive above the speed limit and not
necessarily get a speeding ticket right
is it recommended no and the law in many
countries including at least Canada and
from what I know the United States it
will state that when you do get a Nikka
which is going to be a religious you
know marriage
um you have to kind of report it and and
get a legal marriage as well side by
side you know does that mean everyone's
going to follow it no we should all
follow the law the law of Allah for sure
first and foremost but also the law of
the land but not everyone does
um and it just it just officiates it but
there's complexities too because for
example in Islam we're allowed to marry
multiple wives we can have four wives
when you look at Canadian law you can't
do that so how's that going to happen
you just register one marriage legally
but then keep the other three not
registered that's not you're not
upholding the law of the land there and
there's a lot of hypocrisy with these
laws too for example in Canada it's
legal to cheat on your girl your wife
your girlfriend whatever but it's not
legal to have a second life I think that
makes no sense a second wife where there
would be rights and responsibilities
you're providing for you're protecting
for that's not legal well the the
argument that Andrew Tate makes is that
when you sign legally under under your
country your country has power over you
now in that sense over your marriage and
why would you want why would you want
that and and and I also think that since
governments and countries are run by
humans they're gonna obviously be
corrupt as well right so so that's a
very valid that's a very valid uh you
know I guess whatever you're asserting I
I get that bro because yeah man-made
laws are never going to go anywhere near
the Divine laws of God therefore you
know we have the Islamic agreement and
the Nika and all that but we also have
the legal one you can do prenups and
write specific things to make the terms
a little bit more concordant with
Islamic law
um that's probably the best advice that
I could give yeah yeah and so uh how how
does one
go about like from meeting a girl to
becoming a wife how does that usually go
about in the Muslim World okay good
question Ben so you meet a girl right
this is done
um either with the presence of the Wali
which is the father or mahram you know
someone there uh once you meet her you
get to know her for marriage right you
can ask questions this is very I want
you to understand to the the power of an
Islamic courting versus Western quoting
Western courting they've kind of
conditioned us and programmed us the
things that you need to you know take
the car on a test drive so to speak you
need to get to know the car know the ins
and outs the specs and all that before
because what if you just make a bad
choice right but it's different when you
take a step for the sake of God versus
doing things with your logic all the
time necessarily logic alone will not be
sufficient right and Andrew Taylor made
that very clear so when you look at you
know an Islamic coding you meet the
woman you ask her many questions my
personal recommendation would be to ask
her various things about her marriage
eligibility right or wife ability so is
she going to be a compliment to your
life is she feminine is she nurturing is
she caring is she someone that's gonna
you know take care of you and want to be
uh complimenting your life or is she
going to be someone that wants to kind
of take charge and try to you know bump
heads and Clash heads with you and
compete with you in a way
um you know find these characters ask
her these things kind of vet her in a
way once you've got that clear
um I don't know how you know correct
this is but you know anyone can do the
research on it there's a Hadith where a
man came to the prophet saws and
basically said that I'm gonna marry this
girl right and the prophet peace be upon
him uh responded did you see her and he
said no I didn't see her so and then he
said peace be upon him he said then go
see her you know and I'm pretty sure
even even you know Muslim women they're
supposed to wear the hijab so they're
supposed to cover up be modest observe
hijab hijab hijab is also
um more of a category or a state than
just a piece of clothing this is
something a lot of non-muslims don't
know either they think the hijab is just
the head covering right but it's not
that is called the specific thing you
wear on the head hijab is basically a
state where you're basically guarding
what God has ordained to be your private
parts so for women it's their entire
body except specific Parts you know
there's a difference in opinion if it's
the face or not
um but definitely the hair the rest of
the Body for men is going to be from
their navel to their knees
so men have a hijab too you know a lot
of people don't know that you're wearing
shorts that cut off at the thigh you're
kind of breaking the hijab as a man too
yeah
um so there's very specific rules for
that can be tight you know fitted
clothing as well it has to be a little
bit loose uh can't see your shape that
type of stuff now this hijab you know
because it's a little bit more on women
because we cherish women more and we
understand you know men are visual right
so look at the wisdom of God whereas
today in modern day they're like oh a
woman can dress whatever she wants to
wear and the guy's the problem it's him
that's you know a perv or whatever right
um so here we have level of
accountability on both parties and yeah
and once this is done it's very it's
very clear you know
she will most likely not be dressed as a
typical Western woman so you won't be
able to see her really right so from
what I'm aware if your intention is to
marry her and physical attractiveness is
a very big part of that we're not shy
about that in Islam right you will be
able to see her from what I know maybe
like without her head covering or
whatever just to make sure that you know
she meets your expectations maybe
specific criteria or preferences or
whatnot obviously I'm assuming it's done
with the with the permission and the
presence of the Guardian
um and she's not wearing anything too
revealing or anything like that I'm
pretty sure that you know that's allowed
in Islam
um just so you you get to see her really
um so that's done once that's done it's
literally
um the difference between Halal and
Haram is to witnesses
as I mentioned so it's just getting that
done and then you guys are now man and
wife under the eyes of Allah
um you know how long does this process
usually take from meeting
the girl to getting married so this can
take as long some people have heard they
do it over months and years even I don't
recommend that at all because a man and
a woman are not alone except that
shaytan the devil is the third person
with them right so I don't recommend
that at all I recommend it to be quick
but it doesn't have to be too quick like
a day but understand if your intention
is to marry her her intentions to marry
you you go to the father right away and
you start this process if you guys are
really down to get to know each other
for the sake of marriage you can learn a
lot about her in a few days it really
won't take that long if you really do it
you know I know today everyone's like
first day then they don't talk for
another week then they go on a second
they they're probably drunk and all this
in the west there's none of that you
know you look at two extremes right one
extreme is this whole Western type of
traditional casual interaction where
you're just hooking up or you're just
getting to know them you're dating right
then you go from dating to a
relationship you're committed now it's
monogamous whatever that means right
once that's done few years later you
feel ready for marriage I know some
people that are not even ready for 10
years in the west you know this is one
extreme but then you also have the Other
Extreme now like I don't know if you
know the show on Netflix it's called
Love is Blind so they tried to combat
that extreme by not get letting them see
each other at all only talking
um verbally right so you only hear what
they sound like you get to know them you
ask them things and then you propose if
you want to and until you you actually
propose and engage to them you can't
even see them at all bro this is also
not Islamic we we in Islam understand
you know physical attractiveness matters
yeah we're visual it is what it is but
it's not everything because the prophet
peace be upon a mention that you can
marry a woman for many things you know
her her status her family money looks
all that but the best thing is her Iman
how religious she is how connected she
is to Allah
I see
yeah yeah
um
yeah so like in in Andrew Tate's
philosophy he always talks about
um there's this thing that he talks
about where there's like a test that you
can do to see if a woman is worthy but
but from hearing what you say
um it sounds like the more Muslim a
woman is and the more attracted to you
her you are and the more you connect
um the faster you can get into a
relationship and and you know yeah and
and it's it's almost like you're judging
engaging that accountability first
before you get in there bro imagine how
clouded your judgment gets when you get
inside a woman bro physically yeah you
don't know her you don't really know if
she's a wife or if she's not but you
just do it anyway and then we as men the
way our minds work is we make a decision
and then we we look at things to support
that decision right it's called uh it's
called I feel like it's called Uh I
forgot what it's called bro but it's
it's this term in neurology it's a very
complex process but it's it's almost
like neurological filtering so our brain
what it does is our sensory receptors
all the information we get we literally
filter out information that doesn't
agree with what we agree with
confirmation confirmation bias exactly
and then we take in only information
that kind of conforms to our biases and
we do that obviously to have kind of
like the self-fulfilling prophecy as we
navigate the world we don't like
cognitive dissonance is a very stressful
thing it's very threatening to our
psyche to our ego so you know when you
have intimacy with a woman before even
getting to know her you're going to look
for things that kind of affirm the
decision that you made the right
decision because we don't want to be
wrong let's be honest right but in Islam
you're very logical you're very grounded
there's no emotions there's no intimacy
there's no physicality no attraction in
that regard just yet so you're making
the most logical judgment you can make
another thing I want to talk about too
is we pray there's a specific prayer in
the Islamic tradition called the
istechhara prayer and this is also known
as the prayer or Dua of guidance right
so when you pray is you know when you're
in the in the sujood position or the
prostrating position or your head's on
the ground and you're praying to Allah
um you basically make Dua or make a
prayer to Allah to basically guide you
to make a decision and people have have
made this the heart of prayer for
deciding what college they want to go to
if they're split between two deciding
you know what decision to make which one
to pick what car to buy if I should get
this house or not you can praise the
hutter for anything and one of the best
things to do is the answer that you get
which is very clear most of the time is
from Allah it's divine knowledge because
we don't have Divine we have knowledge
that affirm our confirmation bias like
you said we have knowledge that appeals
to our ego our emotion at the time our
mental state during that day whatever
you name it or maybe even just physical
how much we we want physical intimacy at
that time right but when you do it Allah
God is giving you the best answer that
you can get to make the best decision
for you for your dean and for your Dunya
for your spirituality and for this life
that we have this material world
so you do that constantly but it's
Dakota for marriage is the best thing
that I can recommend because you
literally have that like you're backed
up by Allah you know you're making the
right decision and then over time it
works inshallah
and uh how do you know if if uh if
you're in a position to have multiple
wives or if you should have multiple
wives and how do you go about it
beautiful questions so a lot of a lot of
women today and we made an episode maybe
you want to watch this later maybe
another uh anyone else watching this
search up the episode we did with
brother Gabriel Romani who's also a
Romanian Weaver
um to Islam and he reverted about I
think 20 plus years ago and uh episode
uh the podcast title is why men want
multiple wives so check that that out
guys if you missed that but anyway we
went in depth into answering that
question into why you know how do we go
about that how do you know you're ready
so islamically speaking
God says in the Quran very clearly
in Surah al-nissa which is the fourth
chapter I believe and Allah says that
you will never be basically fair you
know Mary Mary you know want marry two
women marry three women or marry Four
Women this is in the third verse of the
fourth chapter
um but if you feel that you cannot be
just to them
or fair to them and you never will then
marry one meaning like you're never
going to be truly equally like 25 25 25
of course but can you can you be as just
as you can with your limited error as a
human being and your flaws and
Imperfections as man of course you can
do that
um polygeny is part of the Sunnah right
and the prophet peace be upon them did
it you know the companions did it a lot
of prophets had many wives a lot of them
had one wife so it's not something
that's obligatory so you're not forced
into monogamy you're not forced into
polygyny you have the choice of which
one to do
I'm pretty sure you also have the choice
if you want to marry or not but marriage
is part of the theme part of the Sun as
you should um and you also want to
procreate have strong kids Empower them
with proper beliefs and systems to kind
of combat today's you know satanic World
um so to speak so basically when you
have four wives best thing I will tell
you is are you where you are or where
you want to be spiritually and
islamically so are you at least making
an effort to pray five times a day you
know of course some people have
um you know their reverts they're
they're working up to that you know
which is very understandable right but
are you praying five times a day are you
trying to connect to Allah are you on
your basics of Islam that's the first
thing number two are you capable
financially of taking care of them
because understanding Islam we don't do
this whole 50 50 you pay half I pay half
none of that can you for sure if a woman
wants to pick No One's Gonna tell her
not to right but it's a men's
responsibility and role given by Allah
to be able to pay all the basic needs
and all that
um unless obviously she wants help but
even then I recommend against that you
know it's your responsibility as a man
um to do that type of stuff and you want
to raise your kids in that environment
too where they're seeing that you know
and they know that you know father's
there to protect us and provide for us
and provision for us you know so that's
number two make sure you're financially
capable number three bro just mentally
too you want to make sure it's a huge
commitment bro one wife itself is such a
big commitment bro four wives is gonna I
can't even imagine that bro I only have
one wife on home he has one wife but
Rami only has one wife some of the
guests that we had on the podcast they
have multiple wives you know and I don't
know how they do it bro because it takes
even even uh on a podcast with Muhammad
hijab and Andrew Tate were dropped like
two days ago you know I'm sure you
you've probably heard of that
um Mohamed job was telling Andrew Tate
that at one point the prophet peace be
upon him had nine lives bro look how
crazy and absurd not not absurd in the
in a sense that you know I'm speaking
against that but just it's so
unfathomable bro that we had not he had
nine wives peace be upon him and you
know he they were wives not nine women
just imagine even nine girlfriends or
anything like were side chicks no but
nine wives bro that is that is
commendable well that was actually but
uh yeah I was about to go into that like
how how do you think he managed to do
that like he was the prophet of Allah
peace be upon him so yeah for him he was
a different type of man than we will
ever be and we all make Dua to Allah may
Allah allow us to be even a fraction of
the man as the prophet peace be upon him
because that was the type of caliber of
man that you don't see today you know
most men will have just one of the
attributes that he has peace be upon him
let alone all of them at the same time
while being the prophet of God messenger
of God you know relaying this message
having this huge responsibility having
your wife your first wife die before
your very own eyes
yeah being born and you know no parents
very soon you know being born without a
father
um you're without your father alive when
you're born and then your mom dies very
soon after
um having all six of his kids all of
them but one pass away before his life
and going through all these trials and
tribulations some people think like bro
why do we have hardships in life why do
we have this why do we have that I'm
like bro the prophet peace be upon him
had all this time's like a million what
really gives us the audacity to think
we're immune from having these like
day-to-day struggles and hardships and
all that yeah yeah I guess that's a good
segue into um
so can you tell me about like the
Shiites and the history behind how that
came about after Muhammad beautiful bro
I wish Rami was here because he could
have explained this much better than I
could but from what I know the Shia
belief was kind of like the first sect
of how you know sects came in Islam so
in Islam we have many sex right but we
understand very clearly that the prophet
peace be upon Him mentioned that you
know in a specific Hadith it's an
authentic Hadith that 72
of 72 out of the 73 sects of my ummah of
the Muslims are basically like people of
the fire from what I read like people
that are not correct nowhere does it say
they're not Muslim is because people of
my ummah but again right we have to say
it as it is
um so the real you know being
like being in the correct path following
the teachings of the Prophet peace be
upon him and in Sunni Islam having the
correct belief which is called Akita
right all of this makes you not deviant
makes you just correct to the teachings
of it so the shias they have a lot of
different types of beliefs
um they pray a little bit different
um they they have some specific
different holidays they believe certain
different things
um from what I even remember I believe
this was one of the main things that
also deviated them is they also believe
that the Quran which is kind of like the
word of Allah right that we have in text
they believe that that was a creation of
Allah
but we
um and that specific sector I believe
was matazilla but I don't want to speak
out of ignorance now this is a logical
country it doesn't make sense to sound
rational because
how can God create word like God's word
that he doesn't know of you know what I
mean because if God is all-knowing if he
has the same knowledge all-knowing and
and it's it's it's it's knowledge that's
a part of him how can he how can the
Quran be a creation it can't so you see
a lot of like philosophy and a lot of
like of these logical you know things
that get misconstrued they they try to
like let go of the real true Islam and
they try to create deviations and
Innovations which are called Bida and
this is how a lot of sex formed you know
and subhanallah today we even have this
one sect again I don't even consider the
Muslims bro to be honest but they're
called ahmedi so when you look at the
ahmedi people they believe that the
prophet peace be upon him was the last
prophet but then they also believe in
this random guy that was there in like
the 17th or 19th or 20th century I can't
remember and he came as like a
Reincarnation of either the properties
or even Jesus or something like that and
they believe in that but they also Leave
the Past peace be upon was the last and
final messenger so that's a
contradiction they have their own
beliefs and they do a lot of kind of
atrocious things too
but that's why we try to stick to Real
Islam Sunni Islam now the question is
why should I even ascribe to a specific
sect if in the Quran itself it says we
shouldn't divide we shouldn't have sex
well the reality is look at what's
happened through all the other religions
God sent you know the Torah and the NGO
the the Torah which is the Hebrew Bible
and then the gospels right I want you to
understand too Allah writing this or
Allah saying this which is in the Quran
is not the same as the New Testament and
the Old Testament the Torah or the Torah
and the NGO are the original text that
God affirms that he sent and he he has
given to Mankind and he's revealed these
but the New Testament in the Old
Testament are not these These are
modified these are there's a lot of
things that were innovated edited
modified put in there taken out a lot of
stuff like that even replaced right
and it's not conserved it's not
preserved so when you look at it from
this point of view you understand that
man has just always been misconstruing
God's word it's like the broken
telephone game you played as a kid you
remember that yeah yeah so so that's why
I understand that even with you know
Islam people are still going to
sometimes take what they believe and
create different sex and all that but we
have so much you know we have Sunni
Islam to basically preserve what
everything is so if there's already
going to be a bunch of sects so niasan
comes to basically you know preserve
what the real teachings are and be the
kind of like the correct methodology so
how do you know like for example the
Bible is considered corrupted
um and you know as you said like broken
telephone
um how do you know that Sunni or the
Quran is is preserved how is that proven
okay beautiful so unfortunately there's
no time to go over everything so you can
watch some videos deaf definitely that I
recommend and I can send you these to
anyone can search how the Quran was
revealed beautiful videos they go into
everything the Quran is the only thing
that we have the exact same manuscript
as at the time of the properties before
them as today we have the exact same
Quran it's never been modified it's
never been edited it's never been
anything has not been altered we have
the exact same one the same Quran that
they've been you know relaying reciting
since the 7th Century the eighth century
when the public was here it's the same
one that we have now so the preservation
there's no doubt that it's the same
Quran in terms of the teachings too as
Sunni Muslims we just try to follow the
same religion that the prophet peace be
upon him and the companions those that
understood the religion the best we just
try to live according to their
principles and the the understood
understanding of Islam that they had
because me and you are over Layman we
can't make our own understandings you
know two people might read the same
verse and have two different
interpretations so we look at the
scholars and the classical perfect
middle path balance Muslims that were
among the private peace be upon him and
we followed
I see
yeah
um and then I just have a few more
things that I want to ask here sure
so what what happens when I go to a
mosque
what what will I what do I do you know
okay beautiful so the mosque or the
Masjid is a place of worship right it's
a house of Allah it's where we go to to
worship Allah to pray now there's many
things that you could do the number one
thing I'll mention that happens in the
Masjid are the five daily prayers so
just like you know you you I was telling
you you know before this recording that
as Muslims we have to pray five times a
day right you can download one of those
prayer apps and it'll tell you the time
based on your geographical location and
it'll tell you the direction that you
have to pray to as well if you just
allow your compass on the phone app
once this is done you do that but in a
much it's sort of like the direction
when you go in the mushroom everyone
knows it's like pretty obvious when you
go now in the Masjid five daily prayers
the main thing you have what's the other
on or the call to prayer uh you also
have nakama after that this is basically
where you hear people basically
announcing and calling to prayer right
they do in Muslim countries a lot that's
basically when you start going to the
mosque you're ready the prescribed times
for Salah are fixed right that we don't
just make up these times right and we
should pray at those times so obviously
as men
um and women it's better but I'm pretty
sure for men it's also obligatory if
you're able to go to a mosque to do it
but there's difference in opinion in
that too
um so even praying at home from what I
know it's better than not praying at all
obviously
um sometimes I pray at home sometimes I
go to the mosque I try to go to the
mosque
um being as real as possible with you
and when you go to the mosque it's a
completely different game than praying
by yourself because in the mosque you
pray in jamaat in in basically being
amongst your brothers it's like a unit
you know in the end energies there and
you really feel connected to a lot it's
crazy it's really spiritual and that's
basically how we pray in the mosque so
you have the five daily prayers
once that's done you can obviously do
volunteer prayers and matter of fact you
can even go to the mosque in between two
prayers let's say you missed the one
before you can go obviously they're not
gonna have the jamaat right like
everyone already probably prayed on time
and then you can go at your own time you
can pray voluntary ones you can go there
you can pray you the the
prayer of guidance right you can do some
solo things it's not like it has to be
like a community people are always there
though to give you that sense of
community and to do the jamaat type of
prayer when it's time uh you have a lot
of uh Quran in the like copies you know
you can pick them you can read them they
should have some English translations
too
they have all of that in the Masjid
additionally they have the Friday prayer
right which is gonna be around dohor
time which is the second prayer of the
day on Friday so going to the Friday
prayer you don't do that day so on uh
Friday the second prayer you do the JAMA
prayer which is the Friday prayer anyway
instead and for that everyone comes you
know most people even the ones that
don't go to the Masjid for the five
daily prayers they probably do it at
home even they show up at the Friday uh
prayer it's around if you you told me
where you are I'm not going to kind of
air it but it should be around 1 pm ish
to maybe 2 p.m ish sometimes you might
even find a third one at 3 P.M most
Majors have different ones so for
example the merger that I go to it has
the first jummah at 12 30 and the second
one at 1 30 because there's so many
people bro it's impossible to have you
know it's like the population is growing
you know but in another busiest city
where my parents live some uh masjids
have five to six German times meaning
like 12 o'clock 12 30 1 o'clock 1 30 2
o'clock you know what I mean just just
accommodate all the the growing number
of people that want to go now the Friday
prayer as a man it is obligatory for you
to go
um just so you know
additionally in the Masjid you can go do
your Nika right get married in the
Masjid you can go have iftar sometimes
in Ramadan the breaking of the fast you
know the brothers come and they eat
together the mother gives food
um you can also go there ask the chef or
anyone there are any questions just like
you're asking me and us and anyone
online where I was gonna be here for you
you can go to the the Masjid and do the
shahada too like officially but you know
you can you can do it by yourself too
um or with me it's not something you
should delay once you get the message
clear matter of fact there was a brother
that I was talking to he's like okay I
understand Islam and I'm ready to do
shahada but I haven't read the Quran yet
like I haven't finished it nor have I
even like opened it I'm not ready yet
and I'm like what are you going to read
after the Quran are you going to read
all the Hadith which is going to take
like 20 years bro like you know what I
mean it's not an obligation to finish
the Quran
um anywhere before you accept Islam to
accept Islam you need to know the five
pillars of Islam and accept that they're
from God like I mentioned and you need
to know also the six pillars of faith or
Iman which I'll you know kind of work
you through
um and if you believe that you're ready
to be a Muslim and that way we don't
know when we're gonna die when we're
gonna live you know what I mean so God
can never you know hold that against you
you know if when when the day of
judgment comes if you were kind of in
the process of accepting but you delayed
it and Allah you know why did you not
accept Islam when it was made clear to
you even though it's your free will but
you know you're you're judged according
to someone who has got the message you
know what I mean you were mentioning
that before like everyone has free will
for sure some people don't get the
message they're going to be tried
accordingly Allah says in the Quran
never will be you know judge a person or
punish a person unless we have sent them
the message right but because we get the
message you can can't use any excuse all
I was going to do it tomorrow or I was
gonna there's no excuse at that point
you know so it's still free well but we
should kind of not delay the shahada and
there's an Imam Imam Tom fouchina I
believe from Utica Masjid in the states
very very beautiful brother he talks
about Islam as a river as a latter so
the the first step of the latter is the
shahada
but do you see how much more steps there
are yeah you can't you can't obsess with
those steps or even worry about them
until you take that first step so no
matter how much you prepare you're not
even on the ladder yet bro but once you
get on the ladder then you start
building and climbing and climbing and
climbing and building that foundation
and that's when you kind of become an
increase yourself as a Muslim yeah and I
just want everyone to know that's that
potentially watches this that I've spent
a lot of time searching for for for the
answers and and to find find god
um and anyone who's on the journey it is
your choice and
I always recommend to keep searching no
matter what you know and always always
be on the lookout for for signs of God
and and when you do see them follow him
you know follow him if you truly believe
no I love that Allah Allah says in the
Quran don't follow the religion of your
forefathers just because it's the
religion of your forefathers so Allah in
the Quran doesn't write oh non-muslims
oh oh people that are not Believers
Allah just says that as a general
principle there's Muslims too that are
just Muslim by name because they're
they're born into Islam but then they're
out here smoking shisha or celebrating
Christmas because they see other Muslims
do it they're not really correct right
so this is written on Muslims and the
Muslims know your religion to question
things constantly question things and
the more you question everything you'll
realize that Islam is the only real
thing that is true in this world nothing
else is real yeah and once you come to
the conclusion then you accept Islam but
there's no compulsion in Deen as Allah
says in the Quran no one's going to
force you anything
yeah yeah
um
so so
you talk about going to the mosque to
pray but what if like
you're out and about or you know like
you'll see you're driving on a vacation
somewhere that's just an example uh how
would you go about praying
on the road or beautifully from the Moss
beautiful so
the correct teaching right the correct
answer to that would be the of course we
shouldn't pray sitting down unless we
like have to or there's no other way we
should still pray standing up you can
like put like your jacket on the floor
where you're basically gonna put your
head on the ground and just pray find
the cable Direction wherever you are
um it should be something you just pull
over or whatever but here's the good
news I'm traveling soon too so I'll give
you the perfect answer in Islam you know
the reason we have so much Hadith bro is
because we have every example of almost
every type of problem or circumstance we
can come across some people find out
like oh you guys are doing the most but
it's almost like we have that because
it's the perfect instruction template
manual you know so one of the things
that we have is the is the prayer of the
traveler right so when you are traveling
right here's the benefit so in prayer we
have Cycles right so a cycle is
basically you know basically when you
saw the prayer you say a lot but you put
your hands around your your waist or
around your belly uh near your navel and
then you basically you know you go down
down into bowing you come up you go down
into prostrating then you come up that's
like a one cycle right so the fudger
prayer the first one has two cycles
for the father for the obligatory
portion it's two cycles that's it very
simple for the dohor prayer which is the
second prayer it has four for the user
which is the third it has four from
Maghrib it has three and then for Isha
which is the last one it has four these
are your five prayers now when you're
traveling the prayers are reduced
so not only are you allowed to it's
actually the Sunnah so you get extra
good deeds so you get good deeds for for
doing obviously what's obligatory but
you got more Good Deeds for doing what's
obligatory and it's part of the Sun as
in the prophet peace be upon and
practiced it so he would shorten the
prayer so you can shorten the prayers
and you can combine them as well I'll
give you an example
so the fudger prayer you don't shorten
that it's already too turaka or two
cycles right the dohor one which is the
second one it has four cycles and the
other prayer has four Cycles as well
correct so the dohor one you can you
shorten it to two cycles now instead of
four
and then you can immediately do the user
prayer right away
so instead of waiting a few hours to do
the other prayer when you're a traveler
you can do the US repair immediately and
that one is also cut from four to two so
you're basically doing two two cycles of
dohor which is half the time and you
immediately do the other prayer too with
two cycles which is half the the cycles
and then you're done uh
and you can do this from the time that
and Asura are both valid it doesn't have
to be any specific time you're traveling
Allah knows your intention you know then
when it's time for Maghrib the Sunnah is
you pray that three cycles of Maghrib
you don't shorten Maghrib but then you
don't wait for Isha you immediately pray
Isha and out of the four cycles of Isha
you again show in that tattoo
so without overwhelming you we can talk
about the details later but you
literally shorten it and combine it when
you're traveling because part of the sun
line you're allowed to do it and it
makes traveling much easier bro
yeah and then how how would you go about
praying like when you're around
non-muslim people you know and you can't
get away from that like and also what if
you like feel and bear like for people
that are first converting what if you
feel like embarrassed you know about you
know doing it perfect so
that's a good question when you feel
embarrassed understand that you can
either satisfy the Dunya and disapprove
Allah like yeah or you can satisfy Allah
and dissatisfied yeah yeah I'm gonna be
honest with you because you seem like
you know you love Andrew Tay and you
like taking things for as it is you
don't like you know blue pill lies or
anything like that so I'm telling you as
it is bro most things you do in life are
gonna be binary in those two decisions
that I've told you yes there's going to
be some things that you can do that kind
of satisfy the Dunya and satisfy Allah
right which is why it's really important
to change your surroundings if your
surroundings are people that if you
satisfy Allah you satisfy them too we
get that sense of communal belongingness
we get that sense of community that
sense of like reassurance you know what
I mean because there's a psychology bias
it's called group think we usually like
to believe what other you know our
people around us believe yeah so if you
have that type of you know environment
you're basically pleasing them and
pleasing God the Creator so it's perfect
in a way uh but obviously you're coming
from a non-muslim background you
probably have non-muslim family friend
that type of stuff it's the end of the
world and I think it's very good and you
know once they know you're Muslim you
can literally excuse yourself you can be
like hey I just gotta go pray real quick
you can like go to like your room or
like some somewhere separate and just
pray
um and then you know or you can pray in
front of them you can do it beside like
you know excuse yourself go like side
two yeah and we did an episode two uh
you can watch it later if you want it's
with a brother his YouTube is called the
Warner and he mentioned when he started
you know becoming practicing because he
was a born Muslim but like myself and
most born Muslims we come into Dean uh
and get religious and practicing later
in her life because maybe sometimes a
lot of us were just taught the teachings
of Islam but we were kind of just forced
because it was our family but we never
really questioned any things we never
had that freedom to choose like you
mentioned which is very good and
powerful and sincere
um so the Warner was mentioning when he
would excuse himself in like Gatherings
or parties and he would go to another
room and pray
um Sometimes some some people would like
be very curious they'd be like bro can I
like pray with you and he was like what
and then he would just kind of tease him
how to pray and then a lot of them it
was it was a dawah opportunity dawa
meaning you know calling to Islam and
inviting other people that's all that
was it's an invitation
um that was an obligation for us right
the prophet saws mentioned that convey
from me even if it's one verse of the
Quran which is like one line you know
um dawah should be done first and
foremost by example than by speech
because people even though
non-muslims khabib said this you know
the MMA UFC athlete he mentioned that
non-muslims don't see don't read the
Quran they don't read the Hadith but
they go based on what they read in you
the actions of you you know what I mean
so if they notice they're all partying
you know doing drugs and drinking
whatever you're you're just refusing
politely you know you're not being
arrogant about it you're not saying
you're I've outgrown y'all you know you
guys need to stop being childish but
you're just like you know what I don't I
don't really partake in anymore
initially they might kind of resent you
or be like what but then over time
they'll be curious and they're gonna be
like oh what is this force that has
taken bent and like made them change his
life for the better and that's how you
inspire people so honestly it's it's
once you understand the value of Salah
it all those feelings of what are people
going to say well let's go away and it's
just making it a habit like sometimes
and we should we should keep our good
deeds and private too right we shouldn't
share these out like because it makes it
it's a little hard to keep it sincere
let's be honest so when you do good
deeds we should keep it private
but
I'm giving you this just for the sake of
kind of you know answering a question
sometimes I'll go to the airport right
and I'll just like Pray when it's time
to pray in the airport in the gates you
know when you're waiting for your plane
and there's seeds there I'll just find a
place I'll just pray bro I know people
are watching it that's what it is I
don't really care is there a prayer room
or prayer Hall in most airports sure I
don't want to go look for it or anything
I'll just pray but I really don't care
um and and I'm not going to be allowed
and reciting super loud and making sure
everyone's like what the heck is this
guy doing you know but I'm just doing it
and it's serving as dawa too it's a
gentle reminder to everyone that it's
like bro this man really doesn't care
about you know where he is or whatever
and look at him like there must be
something there what is so powerful that
he's he's worshiping he doesn't care
that you know what people say or what
Society thinks so basically what you're
saying is like
and so whatever you're comfortable with
and and being authentic you know any way
that you can be authentic do it you know
go yeah if you need to go find a private
room then do that but the key is to be
authentic to a lot and the key is to do
it more important than where you think
you know it so we also have another
spiritual disease of the heart it's
called Ria in Islam which is like
showing off so you're also not supposed
to know pray super loud and try to seem
super Pious just to flex on people and
appear more Muslim than you really are
you know what I mean that's also
spiritual disease or you see that a lot
of people they're like really hard on
people they're flexing they're like oh
you don't you don't know this you don't
know that that's not the right you know
wisdom that we need to carry as Muslims
so being authentic just like you
mentioned bro and again it's all about
like the intention it's not about the
specific example because there's there's
so many situations you know but at the
end of the day what you're saying is
it's all about the intention behind it
you know yeah correct bro I believe this
is one of the Hadith the one of the 40
Hadith
where it mentions action that the
prophet saws the prophet peace be upon
Him mentioned that actions are judged by
nothing but their intentions
so for example
if you make a video right
and you gave away let's say a hundred
meals to poor people
or orphans or whatever homeless people
and you filmed it you recorded you put
on YouTube right if your intention was I
want to help these people and the only
reason I'm recording is to inspire other
people to do so Allah is going to reward
you accordingly but if your intention
was to get clout to get impressed and
liked by the people you're not going to
get those good deeds
so in Islam we have good intention but
also good action so you can't have good
intention and bad action for example oh
I met well but I'm doing the wrong thing
you know what I mean for example I'm
gonna sleep with a non-muslim girl I'm
gonna have into intercourse with her
um because eventually I'm gonna bring
her into Islam or guide her into Islam
that's that's a good intention bad
action you can do that another way but
conversely you kind of good action and
bad intention so you can't be let's say
doing dawah or wanting to become a
scholar or learn things just for more
followers or fame your intentions are
corrupt that's why you're in Nia which
is called intention has to be in check
and we must constantly as Muslims renew
our intention when you are near just to
make sure we're sincere and we do
everything for the sake of Allah
um
yeah
um
okay so so the last two questions I have
here or I guess three
um so can I go to parties and abstain
from alcohol and sex
um okay no I will I'm not a scholar
right so anytime anyone asks me like a
photo or like a ruling I'm not qualified
to in any legislative position to give
photos a ruling I can only relay to what
I've heard some Scholars say but even
then take it with a grain of salt and do
your own research but it in in if it's
something that you can avoid and you
know you're going to be very tempted to
right this is my advice and you know
you're gonna shaitan's gonna be at your
feet bro you know and you you're going
to be consumed in that old lifestyle and
you're going to want to partake then you
shouldn't go
but if it's something where it's like
a festivity like it's a yearly thing or
you know everyone comes family comes
it's a gathering they're gonna be
offended you're gonna sabotage your
relationship with your family if you
don't go or your your community your
circle your people and you go but your
intention is just to be there for your
family you don't partake in any rituals
with the definitely with the Neo of
having those false Idols or anything you
don't do anything like that you don't
take any in toxins or anything like that
then there is an opinion I don't know if
it's valid or not but it is permissible
then because you're going it's kind of
like going to a birthday party where
it's like you don't want to clash too
much with your family and you want to go
and be like all of a sudden a Muslim I
don't do birthdays anymore you know I
mostly want to do Christmas yeah you
don't you know in in my sabotage your
relationship you might get disowned or
it might be like some big chaos we hear
some things happen because people are
emotional let's be honest then it's like
a lot of I've seen a lot of opinions
saying you can go but just don't
participate you know you know have the
cake but don't like don't don't believe
in what the non-muslims believe why the
the cake tradition was started as a
pagan holiday
um or anything like that don't drink
don't you know what I mean
um that's gonna be one more thing too
and it's the same thing with like Haram
meat so for example as Muslims we have
halal meat which is yeah no pork but
also the meat has to be Halal so the
chicken and the beef you most
restaurants nowadays have a lot of meat
you can ask them and you definitely you
can go to Halal butchers now instead of
non-hollow butchers so Halal uh
slaughtering is actually just a very
humane way of slaughtering
um and it's like the best way with the
animal literally submits there's no
cortisol in the system the animal
literally is blessed and it tastes
really good too uh just as a bonus but
we as we as Muslims that's what we have
so now when you go home your family has
Haram meat right they probably don't get
halal meat
um let's say forget pork we don't have
to have pork even the meat is not Halal
it's a struggle you know so you got to
find out how to navigate that obviously
you know telling them maybe hey can we
switch to Halal me and and you know
again the most important thing I told
you though is the shahada is the belief
are you a Muslim you're Akita Halal and
Haram are you practicing or not these
things are secondary obviously they're
very important nonetheless but the most
important thing is that you're a Muslim
the prophet peace be upon a mentioned
that every son of Adam is a sinner the
best of Sinners are those that repent
and he also peace be upon him he
mentioned that if mankind did not sin
Allah would destroy them and replace
them with a civilization that does sin
just so they can repent and understand
God's mercy so understand bro we're all
Sinners I'm not saying no continue in
your in your ignorance and arrogance
yeah we're all Sinners so I need you to
understand that becoming Muslim is first
then it's like working at all these
things and rectifying it and it takes
months it takes years for some people
but it's a lifelong private Journey you
never compare yourself to another man or
woman's Journey
yeah and I guess like the the main point
here is going back to the intention part
of it and and like if your intent is to
do good and follow God then if you do
Halal or or if you can do Haram then you
can repent always you know of course
always always so when you when you do
Haram and inevitably bro none of us are
perfect we shouldn't but sometimes we do
and we slip into these things just
repent next time you pray right away you
know make wudu which is like the
purification before you go pray and then
when you pray just just make make the
world repent to Allah to forgive you be
sincere and and also make Dua to make it
easy for you to stop that sin
mm-hmm yeah and uh just
to uh ask about Andrew Tate
um are are people allowed to smoke
cigars
are people allowed to smoke cigars again
can't give a [ __ ] though I can't give
all around but from my limited Layman
understanding I'm a Layman and a half
bro
um but from my limit understanding no
because you're imitating the kofar
you're imitating the disbelievers the
prophet peace be upon him very clearly
mentioned not to imitate the
disbelievers the polytheists or anything
like the mushakeen nothing like that so
if if the non-muslims are out here
um you know
smoking cigars it doesn't make it okay
we shouldn't do it it's some some of
it's also harmful but also when you look
at stuff like shisha too you can't just
imitate them because even though they're
Muslims they're doing something Haram so
you don't imitate the disbelievers
um and also just don't do hold on pretty
clear
yep yep and last thing I have by the way
just to quickly mention this to you too
it's better that you are a Muslim that
smokes cigars then a non-muslim that
abstains from cigars
basically a lot of people have been
commenting heat from Andrew Tate you
know because people are like oh but he's
a misogynist he's this listen
I have a question for anyone watching
this
do you think Allah would have granted
him Jannah
as easily I know obviously the only way
to get Jonah is through the mercy of God
let's be honest right but would it
matter if he was a like a non-muslim
let's say he was a Christian like he was
but he dropped the misogyny would that
matter more to Allah than a Muslim who
has a little bit of massaging that he's
working on
like that's something we're going to ask
ourselves Islam comes first no matter
what of course
but just to give you two bro I have a
few minutes I want to quickly uh wrap
this up because I'm actually traveling
tomorrow so yeah yeah inshallah if you
want to give any more questions uh we
can just blast through them all right uh
this is just the last question actually
so
um as as a Christian converting
when and how does pilgrimage take place
the perfect so so Hajj takes place in a
specific time of the year you can
actually Google it you can literally
type like Hajj 2023 and you can find out
when it is
um and you basically just go at that
time you book in advance
um now they have like a new system where
you have to go through to basically
reserve your spots that's Hajj that's
the obligatory pilgrimage right but we
also have What's called the umrah u m r
a h these are the voluntary pilgrimages
that you go I've been on umra for
example but I've never been on a HUD yet
inshaallah go soon uh maybe even you can
join us one day when we go but when it
comes to umrah omra is the voluntary one
that you can go anytime pretty much any
time of the year more or less but Hodges
there's a specific time you can go and
it's like a multiple week thing and you
go and it's it's a very good spiritual
experience wipes you of your sins and
all that if you're very sincere
and also I'm gonna say this if you
didn't already know when you become a
Muslim you already wipe your sins so
this is something that you will get like
a benefit you get that I didn't even get
I'm kind of envious but I say mashallah
I'm not trying to be envious I'm just
joking but you know we as Muslims we we
have a lifetime worth of sins like born
Muslims of course we can repent and
inshallah forgives us but there's not
like guarantee but you basically have a
guaranteed free Clean Slate once you
become Muslim everything is basically
wiped clean for you all your sins but
you keep your good deeds so for you
you're kind of like a brand new newborn
baby you're born with no sins now that's
the good news right but the bad news is
now there's a little bit more pressure
like you want to keep that clean track
record you know what I mean
um but either way whether you struggle a
little bit or you struggle a lot just
know you're basically starting with no
sins
wow yeah yeah that's pretty much all I I
had questions for it
perfect bro yeah how do you feel now
I I feel very um
very
like
satisfied you know like I I feel like I
um you know I've always
been searching for God and I still will
obviously but just like having my
questions answered by someone who is
more knowledgeable than me is very
very relaxing and very satisfying
you know yeah bro and I wanna I wanna
give this uh to you two and to the
viewers too that there is a lot of
brothers and sisters that reach out to
us like Ben a lot of them we don't even
post because we don't need to post all
of them
um but we do a lot of them and we help
these people so if there's anything you
guys need
DM or me at firefit or DM the three
Muslims at the three Muslims uh one of
us will get back to you
and I like to always follow up with
these people too because as Muslims bro
we shouldn't be fake and we have to
practice what we preach because just
like you mentioned the sincerity has to
be there so you can take this as an oath
from me as as in like a promise from me
you can guarantee that I'm gonna make
sure I stay in touch with you too it's
not just like a one and done type of
thing because at the end of the day like
I wouldn't want that for myself if I was
a river into Islam you know because it's
it's like a whole new world you're like
you're now Muslim and you have a whole
new identity and it's like the process
of integrating this Islamic identity
into your identity is the hardest thing
for many people so I want to kind of
make that as easy as I can for you but
do you have any other questions anything
else you kind of want to get out of the
way or do you feel kind of relaxed and
ready
um I guess the last thing I want to say
is is uh if anyone's still questioning
Islam or they're on the fence about it
keep searching you know don't stop and
and don't stop and and like
revert back to what you're just
comfortable with you know keep searching
for for the true God and and never stop
you know even if you have found comfort
in what you believe keep keep looking
out for wrong and for good you know
always
inshallah man the most powerful bro
because at the end of the day Allah
guides who he Wills for one Dua that is
never rejected as the Dua of guidance so
if you're not Muslim watching this just
as brother Ben beautifully he said you
don't know how to probably pray like the
Salah like the Islamic way right you
don't know how to you know pray like
that but just just take your hands bro
just take your hands just make the world
to Allah or go in that position make Dua
to Allah this is between you and Allah
there's no like specific way to make Dua
like obviously there's better ways
authentic Ways part of the Sunnah but
there's no like correct only way you
know what I mean
and make it easy for you guys and to
guide you if you keep doing this Allah
will guide you to the correct path
inshallah yes Coachella perfect bro so
what I'm going to do now is I'm also
going to send you this in uh DM
because
I want to make sure you at least have
that with you
um so you can read this as well
okay perfect so I just DM do this on
Instagram
um so this is basically the shahada uh
it's in English and it's in Arabic too
so we can do it in Arabic then we can do
it in English but you have the
transliteration there for you the reason
I gave you the transliteration is
because I don't want like what I'm
saying to be kind of lost you know what
I mean through the audio sometimes when
you're on the phone the letter M for
let's say movie sounds like the letter N
for let's say uh Nancy right so M and N
kind of get a little bit distorted
sometimes so just just a simple example
so I don't want any of this to kind of
go off the wrong way
gotta keep it correct so let me know
when you pull that up yeah I got it
perfect so you can just repeat after me
Ash hadu
online
muhammadan
muhammadan
rasulullah rasulullah
I bear Witness
I bear witness that there is no God but
Allah that there is no God but Allah and
I bear witness and I bear witness that
Muhammad
that Muhammad is the messenger of Allah
it's the messenger of Allah
congratulations bro Allahu Akbar you're
a Muslim now how do you feel
no different no different you already
knew this was coming yeah I did know
this is coming yeah yeah okay
um now just real quick do you still have
no questions or do you have something
else on your mind because sometimes
after reverting a lot of people have
some new questions
oh I mean I'm sure like things will come
up but I mean not that I can think of
right now I just wrote down like things
that I had in my mind cool and you can
always DM me too
um maybe in the DM tools any of my
personal number so you can just text me
or anything like that and the inshallah
we can keep in touch no because you are
not Muslim understand all of your past
sins have been wiped clean but you keep
all your good deeds now you are on that
first ladder in the analogy you've not
got on the ladder you're Muslim now
right so you already crossed like the
biggest bridge that I can tell you and
I'm being honest with you bro you
literally crossed the biggest bridge the
reason that you know Allah will
basically give salvation to the Muslims
that are obviously Pious and trying to
become good Muslims is because being
Muslim makes you different than anyone
else bro and I don't see this in an
arrogant way I say this in a Pious way
because of all the things I was telling
you about bro a Muslim takes care of
himself of others we pay the zakat we
help charity we give we give to society
more than a non-muslim we have God level
accountability
a society of Muslims is better than
non-muslims that are kind of just
looking for the right path so that's why
being a Muslim now places you in really
high honor than non-muslims so because
of that you already got that bridge but
now we need to work out becoming a
better Muslim so obviously learning how
to pray I can send you like a YouTube
video on how to pray take your time with
it you know
um and remember take every day at a time
one at a time there's no rush you're
going to be you know even some of the
best Scholars bro when they were asked
in like their end of days they were like
asked you know what do you regret doing
and they're like oh if only I started
reading Quran sooner or if only I
started getting on D2 and these were
people that dedicated their whole life
bro they're saying that so you'll never
become perfect obviously the only thing
that's perfect is Allah the Creator but
just do your best every day and
inshallah I think you'd be good then I
just want to say like like I I said that
I didn't feel any different but the fact
of the matter is like once I got on this
call I felt I did feel different when I
got on this call because
I feel like there's a community on the
other side of it you know and moving
forward it's going to be different it's
going to it's going to feel different
but when I say it when I say the the
initial prayer it didn't feel
different yet but I know that in the
future it's going to be totally
different yeah because the shahada the
shahada is like it's it's you just
basically coming to terms with your ego
that you're not Muslim but deep within
your heart you probably already felt
that like long ago you know the shahada
of basically the shahada that you have
internally long proceed precedes the the
child that you do verbally because your
soul your spirit already knows what's
what you know you probably already knew
you know even if some of these things
you didn't release it right with you and
some of these laws and hello Haram you
probably knew it's still the truth
and yeah Gabriel always talks about this
on her Channel he says a lot of people
make the mistake of thinking that the
truth has to be something that you agree
with
no one ever said the truth has to be
something you agree with bro exactly
yeah the truth could be literally
something that you completely disagree
with it doesn't make it not the truth so
you already knew your Muslim this is not
the childhood you've kind of officially
you know become Muslim and you you've
come to terms with on your ego but there
is a community bro and I'm here for you
everyone else is here for you more than
two billion people bro are here for you
and the thing with Islam is you'll go to
the Friday prayers bro like I mentioned
when you go to the Masjid and you'll see
you know people that are white people
that are black people that are Asian
people that are brown people that are
Latino you know they're gonna come in
some some in business suits some in
construction gear some and whatever and
they're all sitting on the same carpet
listening to the same instrument because
we're all equal in the eyes of Allah so
so for anyone watching that does do the
shahada uh like me
what next what should I go to seek what
should I perfectly now the most
important thing I would say is the
pillars of Islam you know the second
thing is the prayer is now so I'll
basically send you a video on how to
pray
um very easy and you just basically
learn how to pray through that
and it's just then getting used to the
prayers if there's one thing that I
recommend for a Muslim before anything
else aside from obviously the belief
is the prayer
prayer is literally an antidote to sins
keeping away from sins
um keep you on the right path keeping
you on the correct trajectory towards
trying to gain the pleasure of Allah
trying to level up your life in Dunya
and in there
um so I just
to keep it very simple just prayers to
learn how to pray get used to the
prayers you know if you want to start
with one obviously you know some some of
the chefs are going to say you know
technically we have to pray five times a
day obviously it's obligatory right but
I'm going to tell you like an answer
from like a brother like just for me you
know it's better that you pray one time
a day for a few days a few weeks even
get that solid then move to two then
move the three then move to four then
move to five and level up that way than
it is to just start praying five times a
day immediately and burning out in a few
months and then never praying again
yeah from what from what I'm hearing
like the the translation of that to
anyone watching is like
your intention is what matters so if
your intention is to be true to God then
take it slow and if you're trying to get
there the journey is what matters and
not like like if you know like oh I
should go pray right now and then you
don't
like if you have that in your brain then
that's wrong but like if you have the
intent to
be in tune with gut then then you will
you will eventually get there you know
yeah as in if you if you have the
intention of praying but you forget
you're not sinful because you literally
forgot or just something came up you
know what I mean and if you have nothing
else to say I want to make sure you have
no questions then I did want to kind of
give you the last thing that I wanted to
say
um just to kind of piggyback off of the
intention thing that you just mentioned
to the viewers
um there's a Hadith where you know in
narrates basically the man who has
killed 99 people I don't know if you
know about this
I feel like I've heard of it but yeah go
ahead so a man killed 99 people and he
basically went to this like he basically
asked everyone like who can I go to I
want to like repent and everyone said go
to this like enlightened like monk in
the area you know and he went to this
Monk and the monk basically said like
he's like how do I ask for forgiveness
how do I like fix my ways the monk base
like you're like you can't forgive
yourself you're you're a sinner you're
done and then the man like off the the
monk too bro made it the 100th uh 100th
victim and then he like went to like a
scholar like a proper scholar you know
and he said that okay you must fix your
ways you must get out of this area
because it's like you know your old area
and this is where you committed all
these things start a new life like just
go away from here and he basically
realized okay I gotta like go to like
this city so here's the city that I'm in
right now and here's a city that I need
to go to right and basically when he was
on that journey to make that that
commitment and change and all this he
died halfway between the two cities
from what I can paraphrase and I believe
the angel of of mercy and the angel of
death or the angel of punishment or
something like that came and butchering
it hella but they basically you can find
this online I'll send it to you and they
were basically debating like which one
is is correct like was he closer to this
was he closer to that
um because you know
it was basically like if if you were
closer to this city the one you're going
to you're going to be basically forgiven
for everything
but if you were closer to the city you
originated from then you were closer to
that so you're not going to be forgiven
um and what happened was Allah changed
the distance
between the guy and the city so he was
closer to the city that he's going to
so then he was forgiven the lesson of
the story is the intention are you on
that train on that Journey or are you
not did you at least make an effort even
if you're one step in the direction see
a thousand journey of a Thousand Steps
all starts with that one step did you
take that first step or did you not
that's all that matters and last thing I
really want to say is is I'm just a
normal guy like I anyone watching this
you know who if you're skeptical about
it or you don't even know anything about
this and you somehow are watching this
keep like just search Learn learn the
ways
and you know
it's it's crazy how far I can get you
you know yeah bro and and like Allah
will always make these things like the
most perfect way possible see over here
you have my uh coaching business that I
run and I have a whole client to all the
people that do Fitness and Muslim
self-improvement coaching you actually
reached out to me via that not through
Instagram not through that and I
literally thought this was gonna be like
a normal thing and we start you know the
coaching thing and you told me
everything about it so I was like bro
this is way more important than this you
know so then that's how we got here in
the first place so it's always going to
be in the most weird perfect ways when
you look back in retrospective was
perfectly the way it was supposed to be
but you just got to take that first step
before today I don't know who you are
bro obviously I knew your name because
we had that appointment but I never
talked to you you never talk to me but
now we're brothers in Islam and this
will not be more than anything else bro
yeah so I really appreciate you for
having the courage to cross this Gap and
to cross this bridge and to just
basically take a step out of confidence
and insurance and Allah than to kind of
submit to your doubts and what's what we
call it what's what's in Islam like the
intrusive thoughts that shaytan gives
you to kind of just pull you off you
know because they're always going to be
there bro
and Allah says in the Quran too that do
they think that they'll say that they
believe
and that they won't be tested anymore
so do you do you do do these Muslims
that are now Muslim they've accepted
Islam they convert to Islam do they
really think their life is going to be
10 times better now and easier and all
the problems are going to go away no
you're in the right step now you're in
the right Journey but you're going to be
tried just to sin but Allah tests the
Beloved believer more so understand
anytime you're being tested is because
there's probably something in your life
that you need to learn or something you
need to overcome or outgrow exactly and
Allah is testing you out of love not
hate and that's one of the attributes of
Allah
the Divine names and characteristics of
Allah Allah is nothing like us so when
people look at Allah's love they make
the error of thinking Allah's love is
like human love as in like humans love
me when they give me what I want you
know so why does Allah give me what I
don't want but they're they're
forgetting that Allah is unlike anything
else creation or whatnot well basically
anything else the creation but
um Allah is not like anything else so
Allah's love is going to be different
than let's see your friends love you
know some people out of love they'll
give their brother like a drink of
alcohol you know or like a blunt and it
might be out of love to them but Allah
is not going to do that Allah wants the
best for you but the question we got to
ask ourselves is do we want the best for
ourselves as well and are we ready to
accept them because you can live a
temporary life of delusion and think
that it's the best thing ever but you
could also live a life of being a good
Muslim and it is going to take
discipline it is going to be harder work
it is going to be a struggle but this
life is temporary bro this life is just
a test the Limitless never-ending
Hereafter is what we're going for
exactly
yeah
cool bro Ben this was real
it was real man it's been loving I like
have no words I have no words I'm the
love bro and you know this is the
sincerity guys if any of you watch this
you know there's there's a ton of other
bends in your area that probably have
the same questions as Ben you know learn
a little bit of Islam you don't have to
be an expert I'm a I'm a Layman bro like
you know but I know a little bit more
than let's say the the average
non-muslim you know what I mean so
that's why I was able to answer these
questions for you to the best of my
abilities and I hope I did
um but if there's anything else again
feel free to reach out to me don't
hesitate you have my Instagram
um but with that being said Ben we look
forward to uh checking back with you in
a few months uh seeing the progress
inshallah if you want to be back on the
channel
um and we thank you for your time bro
for sure bro and the greeting that we
say is assalamualaikum and then for you
you would select the person that's on
the recipient end they would say
so basically means peace and blessings
be upon you
and
means peace and blessings on to you as
well like you're just returning that so
salaam alaikum bro sorry
foreign